um hi everyone
um and welcome to the to the code
breakfast
um i'm marcus and i'm a phd student
focusing on
on machine learning with time series and
one of the
core developers of sk time and i'm
i'm really happy to to be here today and
to work through this tutorial
with you um i'm joined by three other
sk time contributors and that is um
franz kiri who's a part-time lecturer at
ucl
and a senior data scientist in industry
and that's patrick rockingshop
who's a phd student at ucl as well with
a focus on epidemiology
and ayushmann seth who's a computer
science
undergraduate student at ucl and they
will be in the chat
and happy to answer questions as we go
along
and help you out um wherever necessary
and we have 90 very exciting minutes
ahead of us i think
and so the main goal is to introduce you
to machine learning with time series
and i think it would be nice if everyone
could um quickly write in the chat high
so that we kind of like
get to know each other a little bit
better before we
before we start
okay nice okay so
this is a beginner-friendly tutorial and
we assume basic familiarity with um
the pi data stack including panda since
i could learn
um but
not much more so no previous experience
of working with time series
is expected and it's also an interactive
tutorial and this is very important for
us
so we encourage you to ask questions
please use the chat
please use the q a feature we encourage
you to run the notebooks
locally or on binder and so if you want
to launch them on binder
you can just go to the to the repo which
is up here
and then you can click the launch binder
button
and you will launch it in the cloud
otherwise you can clone the repository
up here and you can then download
the repository and launch the jupyter
number locally for more instruction i've
explained this here how to get started
but yes please um use the code to play
around with it
and we encourage you also to you to
raise an issue on github
if anything doesn't look right or always
buggy
um so so just to emphasize this is a
this is a tutorial for you and we're
here to kind of like guide you through
it
and to help you so the
the main learning objectives
actually let me start the the first
notebook
um
yes so this is the the introduction
notebook
um
[Music]
the zero zero intro and
the main learning objectives are that
you learn about
the different um machine learning
problems and learning tasks that you may
come across when
working with time series data and
especially
how you can tell them apart and you will
also learn about
[Music]
different kind of specialized time
series algorithms and different ways
and to build composite machine learning
models to solve these problems
um and the the goal of the tutorial is
not so much to
propose new algorithms or to kind of
like do
comparisons of algorithms to find out
which one is the best
but rather to highlight two things and
the first one is that
there are many problems in pitfalls when
you simply use um
kind of like psychic learn and to solve
time series problems
which is which is not designed um for
these types of learning tasks
and second that there are many
interesting and effective
other strategies of dealing with with
time series data
that go beyond what psychic learn and
most of the other kind like tabular
toolboxes can offer
and throughout the tutorial we will make
use of
sk time and sk time is a new python
toolbox
for machine learning with time series
and the idea of sk time is to extend
cycle learn
to the time series setting so we follow
psychic learn's
logic and syntax wherever possible
so a lot of the code should look um very
familiar to you
but we also develop and implement new
machine learning tools and techniques
especially for for time series
there are also other a number of other
um
time series toolkits out there and here
i mentioned a few of them
and we have a more complete list of kind
of like related packages in software
in the python ecosystem and when you
follow this link
in our main repository again feel free
to
chat to us or to raise an issue if if
anything is missing
and sk timer is a relatively
young toolbox we started a bit over a
year ago
so some features are still experimental
and
will have to be consolidated in the
future so again please make us aware if
anything
um breaks or if you find any other
shortcomings or bugs
in terms of the structure um we want to
start by giving you an
overview of the different time series
data formats
that you may encounter in real world
problems
and the different learning tasks that
you may need to solve
when you have these data formats
um and then we look at two learning
problems in particular um forecasting
and time series classification and then
for each one
we will show you how you can solve these
tasks with um standard approaches
approaches um including psychic learn
algorithms but also more specialized
time series techniques
and algorithms which we provide in sk
time
and then we conclude by giving you an
outlook
of how you can contribute to sk time
and where we kind of like csk time in
the future
um i think it also makes sense to have
um a 10 minute break in between so
perhaps after the first hour or so
that would be after the the forecasting
um session or notebook i think
okay so before we start um
if you have any questions now please
feel free to
to ask them um
[Music]
and again please don't hesitate to put
them in the q a or chat
um it's it's i think it's the first time
for
for many of us to give an online
tutorial
so it's even more important to kind of
have like a um
to get some feedback and i i really
appreciate if you
um kind of like actively listen um by
giving me some reactions in the chat
um kind of like indicating whether you
can
whether you can follow me uh whether i
go too quickly or too slowly
um or whether anything is still unclear
and please also um please also feel free
to share
related resources in the chat um
and then all any any questions that we
that we cannot answer in the q a
on the chat now we will put on the
the discord and we we're happy to to
discuss it afterwards
okay so see there's one question in the
in the q a
um yeah so wait some of the questions i
will try to answer live and other
questions um
[Music]
um the the other contributors can just
answer quickly in the
in the chat um
okay so
[Music]
um is everyone ready to go with the
notebooks there's still an open question
on
yes okay so there are many questions now
in terms of
what's the kind of the difference of sk
time um
and how it compares to existing
toolboxes um
in the throughout the tutorial we will
kind of like make references to
to other um to kind of like a paper that
we published on why we
created um sk time and i guess also
working through the tutorial will make
clear what the
what the purpose is of sk time and how
it compares to other toolboxes
in short um sktime is a unified toolbox
so many of the or all of the existing
toolboxes to our knowledge
um focus on a few particular learning
tasks like for example profit focuses on
forecasting
um um and some of the other toolkits i
mentioned down here
and focus on time series classification
only or so on
and the idea with sk time is to create a
unified toolbox for
time series so that you can make use of
um
kind of like relations between the
different learning tasks and
use algorithms for one task and to solve
another task
okay um let's go to the
the first um proper notebook
and let's make a let's make you start
um so we'll start by doing some
conceptual groundwork um and in this
notebook we're trying to give you
an overview of the landscape of machine
learning with time series
and i think this will really help us to
clarify some concepts
and to help us better understand what
machine learning with time series is
about
and in what respects it's different
from standard machine learning as
presented in scikit-learn
or in most textbooks and this will
hopefully also enable you
to go off on your own after the tutorial
and see
where your own work is situated and help
you in your search for more
useful resources and in particular
you will learn about different data
formats that arise in a temporal data
context
and different learning tasks that may
arise
in in such a context and how to tell
them apart
and some of this may seem a bit obvious
to you but i think it's important to
clarify these concepts
um before we before we kind of like
start to
to do like write algorithms and try to
solve learning tasks
which are really without having um
distinguish them clearly
um okay so time series comes in in many
shapes and forms
um and let's start with the kind of like
simplest case here
um so we only we only have a single
series and to make this a bit more
tractable we will consider an example so
let's suppose
we are meant to analyze um data from a
chemical reactor um
and i guess the the goal could be to
improve the outcome on or the product
of this kind of chemical process um
or to like optimize um the control
system
in like a smart way and the chemical
process takes place in
in this bioreactor we have um a little
image here
of the bioreactor and the bioreactor is
essentially a container
in in which chemical processes are
carried out and
it allows you to control the process for
example you can control the inflow of
oxygen or the
the speed of the aggregation system
but what we're mainly interested in is
that the bioreactor also allows you to
observe and measure
certain variables throughout the process
and yeah so in particular it allows us
to take certain measurements repeatedly
over time
using some sensor in the reactor so this
gives us some time series data
and in the simplest case we observe a
single time series of measurements
and the time series that we observe
um consists of both the time points at
which we make measurements
and and the the kind of values that we
measured
and let's say that we measure the
pressure
inside of the reactor over time and
here i've prepared some data at the
bottom of the notebook you will find the
reference um
to the data set and i've just written a
little helper function
so in this first line we just load the
helper the the data loading function
and then we can load the kind of the
prepared data
and we can plot the single series so
this is this is a single time series of
pressure
and now the the question is suppose that
we only have this time
series what are some some real world
problems
that you may encounter and that you may
want to solve with machine learning
um so two of the
of the two uh most common ones are
time series annotation um and kind of
like special cases are
outlier or anomaly detection on
segmentation
and here you want to assign a label to
each
time point for example whether the
measurement
at a particular time point is an outlier
or not
or perhaps you want to find change
points in the process
um at which the kind of like the overall
dynamics of the
of the process fundamentally changed um
so in time series annotation may be
useful for um
if you want to develop like a live
warning system or as an analysis of
where potential falls occur during the
during the process that you observed
the other main learning task is um
forecasting
and here you want to make a temple
forward prediction
using um the available pass data
and this may be useful to inform the
control system of potential future
changes to the process
so that you could have an early
detection
system that uses predicted data to make
smart adjustments to the process
um okay so much for the kind like
simplest case
um how's everyone doing was that too
slow
too fast um are there any
any questions i see there's one in the
um one in the okay this is still an open
an old one
all right thanks all for all of the
feedback looks like it's all going well
okay um
[Music]
so the next the next complication is
that you may observe
multiple series
and here it gets a bit more complicated
because this can happen in fundamentally
two
two different ways the first one is you
can have multivariate time series
where the time series are closely
related
or you can have panel data where you
observe independent instances
of the of the time series
and we start with multivariate data so
here we observe
two or more variables over time and for
example the pressure
and now also the temperature of the
process as well
and um just to kind of clarify some
terms here so variables
um represent different kinds of
measurement like for example temperature
or pressure
um and they we take them
within a single experimental unit in
this case the experimental unit is the
the the bioreactor run
so we observe a single bioreactor run
and we take different kinds of
measurements
um so it's important to note that we
still only observe a single bioreactor
run
and but now more than just one variable
and again we can ask the question
um that if we have this type of data
um what are some kind of like real world
problems
um that we may want to that we may have
to solve
and that we can actually answer with
this type of data
um so as before we have like variants of
the
of the annotation and the forecasting
tasks and but now we have access to
additional variables so we can make use
of them
and for example now we can use
not just the pressure but the pressure
and the temperature combined
to see if the the process at a
particular time point
um was was like an anomaly on outlier
or just a normal observation and
similarly with
forecasting we could now use the
additional variable as an exogenous
variable
and see if that can help us to
make better um predictions for the
for the future of the process or
and we could try to to forecast both
series
at the same time and so we forecast
multiple series at the same time and
this is
usually called vector forecasting
okay so the second way in which we could
observe multiple series
is panel data or sometimes also called
longitudinal data
and this is where things change a bit
now
because here we observe multiple
independent instances
of the same kinds of measurements and
for example readings from the same
sensor
from different runs of the chemical
process or the
the bioreactor and i've plotted them
here
so each so this is all um
different measurements of pressure over
time and each color represents a
different run
and it's important to note that
this kind of like difference between
having multivariate data
where time series are related and
possibly the dependent on each other and
having panel data where we can assume
that um
the different runs are statistically
independent
and also note that panel data may be
multivariate um
so we can have independent and
identically distributed instances
of multiple time series so we could have
um
observed pressure and temperature for
multiple runs
and in this case still the instances the
different bioreactor runs that we
observe
are independent but the
the time series and within each instance
may still depend on each other
also note that panel data may be mixed
so maybe we observe some time constant
variables
um for example maybe we observe some
fixed
settings of the bioreactor like the size
or some fixed and control variables
which cannot change over time
and again we can ask the question um if
we observe this type of data
what are some real world problems that
you may encounter
and that you may want to solve with
machine learning
and so we have
what we call supervised variants of the
annotation and the forecasting task
and this now basically works as follows
so
if you observe multiple runs um and you
have
labels for the time points for the
different series
you can try to learn the association
between the
between the process and the label
for the from the training set from the
label data that you have
and then once you've learned this
association you can try to predict the
labels
of the new series that you get of a new
um bioreactor run which isn't labeled
yet
so that's kind of the supervised time
series annotation
variant um similarly for forecasting
um if you observe multiple bioreactor
runs you can
try to make use of um
[Music]
the consistent patterns across
different bioreactor runs um in order to
predict um
the the the future values of a of a
single
um series
and but also with panel data we um
can solve um kind of like what we call
series as features learning tasks
um and these are direct extensions of
the learning tasks that we have in
scikit-learn
um so we have time series classification
we have time series regression
and time series clustering clustering um
and what the goal is here is that we
observe a time
series and in classification we want to
find the relationship between
the series and an individual label so we
try to assign a label to an entire
series
and in classification this label is
discrete
and in regression we have the target
variable um
which is continuous and then in
clustering
we're interested in finding um
clusters of time series based on the
similarity
between entire series
and i've hinted at this before um
we have to be aware of the kind of like
statistical
and dependency structure of time series
and i guess the first point is quite
obvious
but an intrinsic characteristic of time
series is that observations are
statistically dependent on adjacent or
past observations
so and this this already indicates that
they don't naturally fit into the
standard machine learning setting
as in cycle learn where we assume to
have
independent and identically distributed
instances
and yes i've explained this before as
well so in multivariate data
it is implausible to assume that the
different um
univariate time series like the
temperature and the pressure
that they are independent um
but when we have panel data it is
plausible to assume that the different
instances
um are independent while the well this
time series are still dependent on each
other
okay so and at this point um having kind
of like
explained and outlined a little bit the
the landscape of time series
um you may wonder why why does it all
matter why do i have to care about this
and the main point here is that well
there are two main points so first of
all is that
um different learning tasks require
different types of algorithms
to solve them so for example if you want
to solve the time series classification
task you need an algorithm or you need a
time series classifier
if you want to solve a forecasting task
you need a forecaster
now more importantly if you misdiagnose
the learning tasks
if you um think um that you have to
solve a different task than kind of the
actual real world problem
um requires um your algorithm
may still work when you when you build
it in
kind of like in your training
environment but it will no longer work
when you want to deploy it
because it it requires certain inputs
that are simply not there in the
in the deployment situation and
even if you misdiagnosed the task in
many cases you can still kind of get the
algorithm to work and you can still
obtain performance estimates
but um these estimates are not are no
longer reliable basically if you do not
take into account the
the dependent the statistical dependence
of the data
um so performance estimates tell us how
well our model will perform
once we deploy it and they basically
allow us to make informed
choices about which model to deploy but
our estimates are only reliable
if we properly take into account the
statistical dependence
of the data that we use to obtain these
estimates
okay let me check if there are
[Music]
many questions in there no okay
so is everyone still doing doing fine
before we move on
um i've seen this like an active chat
i really appreciate this thanks for all
of the the questions and comments
okay nice okay so let's
let's move on so there are there are a
few more complications which we kind of
brushed over here now
um in many real world applications
we find um what we call time
heterogeneous data
so the instances or variables may not
share a common time index
and examples of this may be that you
have that the
that you have unequal length time series
data so maybe the
the number of time points that you
observe for the pressure variable are
not the same
as the the number of time points that
you observe for temperature
you may also observe um timestamp data
so instead of observing
um measurements at a like regular
regularly spaced interval you observe
measurements at
exact time points
or for example maybe the different
sensors have different sampling
frequencies
um and so the the time indexes
do not um align so maybe the pressure
sensor
samples your the and the pressure from
the process at like a five second
frequency
and the temperature is um sampled at the
three second frequency
um and in general this kind of like
having these different data formats
raises the question
how to represent this kind of data and
for the purpose of
machine learning and usually
instances what we described here as
instances so they can like
independent and bioreactor runs are
represented in rows
similarly we have um variables and
um or columns um variables represented
as columns
um and then the time series setting
introduces a new dimension to it
kind of the temporal dimension the the
time points that we observed
um and it's not it's not immediately
clear how to like
best represent this um so there's
there's a like an ongoing
um debate um about the which former to
choose
um so whether we want to choose the
white format where we
represent time points as columns but
that has certain drawbacks
or whether we want to choose the long
format um as in a relational
database or any other format and
similarly there seems to be no consensus
in the kind of like
python community about which data
container to use whether to use um numpy
pandas
or x-ray or even the custom data
container
and for more details on on this kind of
like issue of how to store and represent
and this kind of data you can look at
our wiki entry
and and there's also notebook which we
included which um patrick wrote
um on the data container development and
the
the kind of like thoughts and
considerations that we took into account
and um we're happy to answer more
questions if that's
of interest either either later or
in the discord afterwards
yes so regarding the the question on the
q a
um
[Music]
yes so if you yeah that's basically the
forecasting um
problem so if you observe um
[Music]
for example the last year and you want
to
and let's say you have like monthly data
and then you want to predict um
the next month of the new year and that
will be a forecasting problem we will
explain the forecasting in more detail
in in our next notebook where we focus
like exclusively on forecasting
okay so to to kind of like sum this up
um
we've discussed different types of
learning tasks in in
briefly how to tell them apart and for
more details you can take a look at our
paper
and here we summarize the um
the different learning tasks in kind of
slightly more mathematical terms
and you can read through them um or go
back to them if anything is still
unclear or if you want to have like a
slightly more like concrete and robust
definition of them
and now what's really interesting with
time series
is that there are so many kind of like
so many of these tasks are
related and until now we focused on on
that these tasks are distinct but
there's this idea called reduction
which essentially says that an algorithm
for one task
in some cases can be adapted to help
solve another task
and a classical example of reduction in
supervised learning is um
one versus all classification where you
reduce um
a k way multi-category classification so
you have k categories and you
you reduce it to k binary classification
tests
um in in the time series domain
um there's also very common example of
reduction
and that's when you try to solve a
forecasting task
with um kind of like regression
algorithms from psychic learn
and this is usually done as follows um
which we try to
to kind of like show in the in the
little diagram
and below here so you observe the time
series and you use a sliding window
to split this into equal length windows
and then you stack on top of these and
then you stack these windows on top of
each other
and that gives you your feature matrix
of lacked
values and for each window you use the
the subsequent value um
as the kind of like target value that
you want to predict
and so this is kind of what we call the
like tabularization
of the time series and once you have
this like tabular matrix
you can fit um any cycle learn regressor
and then generate forecasts from it we
will just explain this again
in in the forecasting example more
detail here the main purpose is to show
that
there are many relationships between
time series learning tasks
and that's also one of the key reason
why it makes sense to have a unified
toolbox
so that you can fully exploit these
relationships
and here we kind of give you a quick
overview
of the different reduction relations
that
that we know of in the time series
domain
what i've just described and going from
classical forecasting
um to tabular regression in fact
involves the number of
intermediate steps and but you can also
of course kind of like directly reduce
forecasting to tabular regression
again if you want to find out more or
look up the kind of like references here
in this little screenshot
um you can go to our paper
which we've also um referenced down here
and um
yes this is the the link to the data set
okay um so
this is kind of the the the conceptual
groundwork
um that i think we needed for
for the more practical work and
yes let me know if there are any
questions at this point before we move
on to the
to the more practical um
forecasting task
yes so the link to the the link to the
paper
um is right here is right under the
under the reduction diagram if you can
see it
um if not you will also find it on the
sk time repository
okay so um let's move on to the
can like first more practical notebook
um which is the
notebook two on forecasting
okay just to kind of like um recap
um in forecasting we're interested in
using past data to make um temporal
forward predictions
and sk time provides um like algorithms
and tools for
for building composite machine learning
models to do that
um and in this notebook
um and we'll
um kind of like look at and both um
connect specific
or statistical models to make forecasts
but also
ways of building composite machine
learning models
including techniques like reduction to
progression
but also other techniques like
ensembling and pipelining
um and we'll kind of like work through
them
um step by step um and then
you can again you can like play around
with the code and ask questions and
um we can discuss them with more in more
detail
and okay so we just um
[Music]
load some preliminaries here
and then for this tutorial we use um
like a toy data set just to clarify kind
of the the concepts
and this is an airline data set which
shows the number of
international airline passengers and
note that this is a monthly data
so the seasonal periodicity um is 12
and by the seasonal periodicity we kind
of mean the number of periods per year
at which we expect them to kind of like
see
um like a seasonal pattern and in this
in this plot you can see quite clearly
that there's a strong seasonal pattern
now before we start building models to
make forecasts
um it is important to
specify what exactly we're trying to
predict
and this is something which is done very
implicitly
in psychic learn um in succulent you
know we'll find um
you never have to like explicitly define
the learning tasks that you're trying
to solve instead this is like implicitly
done
by your choice of estimators of whether
you choose a regressor or classifier
and also um through the separation of
the
of the x and the y the features and the
target
in the interface or the signature of the
fit function
in forecasting you need an additional
piece of information
um namely the forecasting horizon
that is the the time points that you
want to predict
and here we define our learning task as
follows
so um we will try to predict the last
three years of data
using the previous ess training data so
each point in the series
represents months as i've said so we
should hold out the last and 36 points
as test data
and then we use a 36 step ahead
forecasting horizon to evaluate our
forecasting performance
and to kind of quantify the accuracy of
our forecasts
we use smart p which is the symmetric
mean
absolute percentage error and to kind of
like interpret this
the lower smartphone means a higher
accuracy
now we can we can use this um the
temporal train test split function from
psychic learn air from sk
and define the test sites as 36
and then we can plot the data and we can
kind of like see
how we split the data into training in a
test set
okay let me load the data first
okay so we have 108 um
observations in the training set and 36
in the test set
okay as i've said we now need to define
the the forecasting horizon
and so the time points that we want to
predict
and here we define it as kind of the the
range from the first step ahead
um to the 36th step ahead
and we can simply define it as a numpy
array
um yes and we can then use this
forecasting horizon to
make kind of the predictions for the
time points that we're interested in
of course you could also write it in a
different way so for example
if you were interested in predicting
only the the second and the fifth step
ahead
you could simply define the forecasting
horizon
as an array like this
um okay i think it it's usually a good
idea to
start with very like simple approaches
to solve your learning tasks
that usually helps to clarify a little
bit what we're trying to do
and um for forecasting two very simple
strategies uh
and first you always use the last value
that we observed so that basically means
if i want to predict tomorrow
um i i just use the value of today
and the second strategy is if i want to
um predict let's say tuesday i look at
the
um last tuesday so i use the last value
of the same season
now if i want to do the um predict the
last value observed to the first
strategy um i could write this in python
a single line
so we take the last value of the
training set here
and we just repeat it for the length of
the forecasting horizon and then i cast
it into panda series so that it has the
right index and that makes it easier
and to plot so we can just plot this and
the green line that you see here
this is basically the the prediction of
the last value
[Music]
okay we can also do this in sk time
and similar to sk time we have um a
similar to cycle learn i mean we have um
a naive forecaster or like a dummy
forecaster
so we can easily specify it and and this
syntax should be very similar to
should be very familiar to to anyone who
knows cycle learn
so we first then build or specify the
model and we can
choose the hyper parameters here
and we then once we have specified the
model we can fit it and here we use the
single
training series and then once we have
the fitted model
we now pass the forecasting horizon to
predict
to generate these predictions and then
again we can plot the data and obviously
it looks the same
and we can also compute the the smartph
loss
um now if we choose a different strategy
so to solve kind of the
the the to use the other strategy the
simple strategy we can
change the strategy and hyper parameter
and put in season or last
and at the same time provide the
seasonal periodicity of the data
which is 12 in this case and then you
can see that
this basically repeats the last season
that we've observed
into the future and this already
captures the kind like seasonal pattern
a lot better
so there's one question in the okay i
think it has been answered already
um okay so this this should um kind of
clarify um what we're trying to do
and now obviously we're interested in
not just building naive forecasters but
kind of like more sophisticated models
which hopefully capture like um
underlying trends and
patterns of the data in a better way
and now of course the question is or can
i not just use psychic learn
and the answer is yes in principle but
there may be many pitfalls and that you
should be aware of and that you should
try to avoid so the first one
which is also maybe the most obvious one
is
if you just use um the trained test
split function from psychic learn
and you split your data you basically
get something like this
so train test split in cycle learn
is built for the setting where we have
independent
instances so it makes sense to shuffle
them and to randomly split them into
training in a test set
now in time series data you have a
different
statistical dependency structure so you
cannot just randomly shuffle the data
because
observations depend on past observations
and if we would use this kind of like
randomly split data
we would run into a problem which is
called
leakage so here the data that you're
using to train a machine learning
algorithm
happens to have the information that
you're trying to predict
so basically if we use this data to
predict the last
um 36 um steps then
as you can see there's already a lot of
training data there that the algorithm's
sold during training
so it makes it quite easy to predict
this um time period
and but of course you could use train
test split from psychic learn and set
shuffle equal to false
and this is essentially what we do in in
the temple trend test
in sk time and when you do this it works
it splits the
it kind of like properly splits the time
series and makes sure that you
properly evaluate the performance of
your algorithm
um okay so the
the second pitfall is that um
[Music]
it's not it's not immediately clear how
to use scikit-learn
since we only have a single series and
this brings us back to the
kind of like idea of reduction so what
we're essentially
trying to do when we use cycle learn is
to
reduce the forecasting tasks that we're
meant to solve to a regression task so
that we can apply a circuit learn
regressor
and um we can do this as follows so
again we we first need to transform the
data into the required tabular format so
that we can put it into the circuit
and regressor and as i've said before we
do this by using like a sliding window
we cut the series into windows stack
them on top of each other
and then always use the subsequent value
as the
the target variable that we're trying to
predict
and we could write some code for this um
so
for example in the m4 competition which
is a famous
kind of like forecasting competition
um we they have written some code and
i've used like a slightly modified
version here
and this function basically does this um
kind of like transformation of the data
for us
so we it takes in a single series um
it also you needs the number of the kind
of like
win the window length which is um the
in-numb
and it needs the the forecasting horizon
or the length of the forecasting horizon
and here the number of um out of sample
points that we want to predict
um okay if we
if we run this function now what i do
first to kind of like
um illustrate a little bit how it how it
works
and i put in not the the time series
values but i put in the
the time index basically of our time
series
i set the window length to 10 and i give
the length of the forecasting horizon
now if we run this i need to define
them the forecasting will rise and here
we go
now if we run this um
we can look at the kind of like feature
matrix that we get in terms of the time
index
and this looks as follows so the first
window is from the first observation
to the ninth so it's got length 10
second one is from 1 to 10
and so on so we kind of use we we can
see this like sliding window
and then corresponding to these windows
we have the target um
variable which for the first window
consists of the next value
for the second window it's the
subsequent value and so on
now this is when we use the the time
index
now we actually supply the the time the
actual values that we observed
um and then do the
the data transformation again um
we can kind of see the shapes of the
arrays
and so we have our feature matrix of lag
var of lag values has um 98 rows
and as expected kind of like a window
length of 10
so we look at the 10 lakh values
and then we have the training target
variable of the same
length okay and once we have this kind
of like format this is what this is what
circuit learn needs
so we can just use any regressor from
scikit-learn
in this case i i chose the brandon
forest
and then we can just put it in and fit
the model
now this all seems to work quite nicely
but um we believe that there are like a
few problems with this and first of all
um this requires a lot of
handwritten code which is often error
prone
and it's also not modular or and not
tunable
so by modular i mean it's very hard to
change
certain components of this can like
process
by tunable i mean that
this this process this type of reduction
involves a number of
of implicit hyper parameters which we
may want to optimize
so one of them is for example the window
length
so the performance of the algorithm
of the random forest and of this entire
reduction approach
is likely to depend on the window length
that we choose
so we may want to optimize the value
that we have by using like a temporal
cross validation scheme
another hyper parameter is the strategy
that we use to generate forecasts
now we have the fitted model but we
haven't actually generated
any forecasts um so far
and how to do that is another kind of
like modeling choice
and that we have to make as a as a
like a practitioner or scientist and
we want to in some cases we may want to
optimize this
and using this kind of like handwritten
approach
and all of this is like very difficult
to implement
now before i show you how we can do this
in sk time in a much better way
i want to kind of like show you how you
can generate forecasts
once you have this fitted model
so um if we print the shapes of the
test set and how the feature
matrix of the test set and the target
variable of the tested
and we can see that we have 36 windows
and each one is 10 long so that seems to
be in the right format
and we have um kind of the target
variable
is is the same this is going to be kind
of like our test set so this is what we
compare our predictions against
and now what we can do is we can simply
put this
in the um in the fitted model
and compute the loss
okay and now the question is what's the
problem here
so this seems to be kind of the the most
natural way of generating predictions
um but given the learning task that we
defined
it's actually wrong
and i think it's important to understand
what's going on here
so when we put in these 36 windows
we use the actual test data
rather than using um kind of like
predicted value or something like this
so in other words instead of making
multi-step ahead forecast so instead of
predicting
instead of having a fixed cutoff point
and predicting
36 steps ahead what we actually do here
is we make
36 single step
predictions so we always move the cut
off
[Music]
but that's a solution to different
learning tasks
and as you can see we can still compute
the loss
and but this loss will be will be
much more optimistic than than the
actual
loss um if we tried if we predicted 36
steps ahead
because predicting only a single step
ahead having almost
always the the most recent um data
available
um is likely to be simpler than than
predicting um 36 steps ahead
so that's i think that's an important
pitfall to kind of like be aware of
and now to fix this problem um
we could write some code to do this
recursively um
as in the m4 competition
[Music]
so what we do here is we define kind of
like an empty list
for the final predictions and then we
get the last window
of the available data that we have so
in this case it's the the training set
and we use only the last window
and then we reshape it to make it into a
2d array so that we can use it in second
learn
and then we use only the last window
that we have
and we generate a prediction and then we
kind of like do this recursively so
we iterate over the forecasting horizon
and for each step of the forecasting
horizon
we first can like append or store
our prediction and then we update the
window
and we update the window by using the
last predicted value that we have so we
use the
the previously predicted value to to
update
the the new window and then once we've
updated the window we can make a new
prediction
of the next step ahead and we do this
recursively until we've
predicted all of the steps ahead um
and then um we can again compute the
loss
and as you can see so this loss um a
smaller loss means a better accuracy
and you can see that if we do it this
way the loss is actually
um higher so with this one with this
approach we would have um
overestimated the performance of the of
the algorithm
okay is this clear so far are there any
any questions how's everyone doing
okay nice um
[Music]
so with sk time um we kind of like
try to make this much more convenient
for users
we encapsulate this reduction step into
meta algorithm
to make it modular and compatible with
cycle learn but also tunable
and adaptive in the sense that it adapts
the psychic estimator interface to that
of a forecaster
and that makes sure that we can tune it
and properly evaluate our model and
basically that we
avoid the the pitfalls described above
um and this is this is kind of what we
tried to represent in this diagram
so we can like wrap the outer robot here
is the the reduction meta estimator
and it wraps the the smaller robot
inside the
psychedelic regressor okay again we can
load the airline data
and we can do the tempo train test split
and then we can import from scikit-learn
this reduced regression forecaster which
is essentially an auto regressive um
regressor so to say so it uses the lag
values as described above
and then we can again use any scikit
learn regressor in this case we now pick
a
k nearest neighbors regressor
we specify the regressor and then we
pass the regressor
to the regression forecaster and
with certain hyperparameters so here we
use the window length of 12
which is the kind of like seasonal
periodicity and we use a recursive
strategy to
make predictions and then this forecast
has the same interface as all of the
other forecasters
we can fit with the training series and
predict with the forecasting horizon
and then generate the predictions
and yeah so this is what i've described
before
this is kind of like how internally we
we split the window
i don't think i have to go over this
again
um so this is kind of the the idea if we
want to reduce the learning tasks to
um a tabular learning task um
[Music]
sk time has also other statistical
forecasters
and like exponential smoothing
or auto reamer which we interface from a
nice package called pmd arima which is
linked here in the text
and in the interest of time i won't go i
won't go through this in detail
i just skip over to the kind of like
more interesting part that sk time has
to offer
and this is kind of the the composite
model building functionality
um so and one aspect of it is
um ensembling and like sk likes i could
learn
and we have a an ensemble forecaster
and where we can combine multiple
individual forecasters
and then average um the the predictions
and we're currently in the process of
developing more kind of like
sophisticated ensembling strategies
um to to combine the forecasts of
individual forecasters
um this syntax again should be fairly
familiar to anyone who knows circuit
learn
and um just to kind of like reiterate
the ensemble forecaster
um wraps individual forecasters but at
the same time
it's a forecaster itself so it has the
same
fit and predict interface as all of the
other forecasters
now that's ensembling and you can also
do tuning
um in a forecasting setting which is
something that sktime provides
so we have the forecasting grid search
cv
and we have different um temporal cross
validators
here we use a sliding window splitter
and again we can we define an initial
window
that we use for training the algorithm
and then
we define we slide over the test set in
order to
to evaluate it for tuning and then once
we have found
a good algorithm through this grid
search cv
we again evaluate it on the on the test
set
so in this case what we try to tune is
the reduced progression forecaster so
this kind of like meta estimator and
specifically we try to find the best
window length
here i only look at um kind of like five
possible values whether 5
10 or 15 is the best choice of course
you could have a
bigger grid of um of um values to search
over
and then once we run this um we will
find that the best parameter is 15
and the kind of like the grid search tv
will be the and we can then kind of use
this with the best value to predict to
make predictions as in succulent
um now another very interesting approach
is is residual boosting or de-trending
and in sk time we we do this um in a
modular way
so here the idea is that you want to
de-trend the time series
and as we can see here so this the blue
line is kind of the original
training set and there's a clear kind of
like linear
trend in the data and um
what we can try to do is fit this linear
trend
and then subtract the trend from the
data so that we only get
the residuals and this is what we do
here so we define a polynomial trend
forecaster of degree one so this is just
like a linear trend
um forecaster and we have this um
the trender um which is a transformer
a time series transformer which
internally fits the forecaster which we
passed to it
and then returns the residuals of the
time series
um and this is basically what's
happening here so
the yt is what we plot here and this is
kind of the
the residuals which we show here
now this is um kind of like interesting
to pre-process the time series
but you can of course also use this as
kind of like a boosting
um strategy for forecasting
so you could fit um any type of
forecaster here
um and and use the forecaster to
detriment the series so now we use like
just a linear trend forecaster but of
course you could also use
something much more complicated like in
a rima model or so
to de-trend the series with the rimmer
model
and then on top of the residuals from
the rima model
so everything that the arima model
didn't capture you can try to
fit the more complicated um machine
learning algorithm
and this is kind of the idea of the
detrender
and we show here how you can like
combine it in a pipeline
um so we we have a transform target
forecaster
which makes sure that you do target
transformations in the correct way in sk
time
so in here the idea is that um
you first want to do some
transformations of the data for example
you want to take out the kind of like
seasonal pattern of the data
and we use the kind of standard
seasonal decomposition technique here
um and then once you've deseased
analyzed it you want to
get the kind of like a linear trend out
of the data
which is what we do next and then
once you have the d trended series you
want to fit um
the more complicated model and in this
case we use the k-nearest neighbors
again
and through this kind of like reduction
approach and we can all put this into a
single pipeline
and again then we have the just the same
interface so we can fit and predict
um and as you can see this strategy
already works fairly well
but again this is this is not about um
showing which algorithms are best
but what you can like show you different
different concepts
of how to solve a forecasting problem if
you're interested in kind of like
algorithmic comparisons
um we've um used these different
techniques and evaluated them on the m4
study
and you can find the link to the paper
at the bottom
um and of course you can also look at
the m4 casting
competition itself
[Music]
okay there's a question prediction
window still
so the the prediction window is still um
kind of like
what we're trying to do is still kind of
like encode it in the forecasting
horizon
so the forecasting horizon here is
still 36 so we still try to predict from
the first step to the
um to this 36 step ahead
um the window length 15 is what's kind
of the look back
how many points in the past um
are we trying to to use in order to make
this prediction
in this kind of like um reduction
approach
um okay there are also other ways
um of kind of like this changes the
learning task basically now the
um if you want to make like more dynamic
predictions uh this is kind of like an
online learning setting
um where you um
want to update your prediction as soon
as you get new data
so um and we have a specific um function
for this kind of the update predict
function
where you can evaluate your model um for
different learning tasks
um like this one um so the dynamic
forecast
um just as the kind of like prediction
intervals which we show here
a still work in progress in sk time
[Music]
and um not kind of like comprehensively
implemented for all forecasters
um and but yes
if you're interested um please get in
touch um
we're kinda like happy to push this
further and this is client part and this
is this is also on top of the
kind of like development roadmap
um okay so in summary um
we've seen how to make forecasts and
we've seen like different forecasting
strategies
um ensembling and de-trending and
pipelining as kind of like novel
techniques
that go beyond scikit-learn
and which we provide an sk time in which
seem to work relatively well in practice
um i've added some links for more
resources here
and this is the paper that which i
mentioned
and where we try out these different
approaches this is a very good
introductory textbooks on forecasting
and then more generally take a look at
the m4 competition
and they're currently running next
iteration of that competition the m5
competition
um okay so i think it makes sense to
have a quick break
um before we go into the classification
um
notebook and we're already running a bit
behind i think so maybe only
a few minutes i need to get some water
just a quick comfort break and then i
think we
we can meet back at um 9 15 in three
minutes before we
and then go into the classification
notebook i hope that's okay for everyone
let me let me know in the chat how
everyone is doing or if you have any
more specific questions
okay i'll be i'll be back in um in a
minute
yeah so there's one question in the q a
um
yes that's that's correct um all of the
steps in the pipeline must have an
inverse transformation
you first transform the data
you then fit the forecaster um
and generate um forecasts and then you
need to inverse
the the forecasted values to kind of
like bring them back to the original
scale
i hope that that answers the question
[Music]
so how's everyone else doing
can everyone still follow
any any more so someone raised a hand
i've seen this before um
please um instead of raising your hand
please um put it into the chat or
or raise the question in the q a okay
there's still the
um there's still the question for how it
compared to
fb profit and i've mentioned this before
um the main difference is that sk time
is a unified toolbox so
profit only use can only be used to
solve forecasting
problems um sk time as we will see in
the next notebook
can also be used to solve other um time
series related learning problems
um yeah i hope this this answers the
question
and i also see that there are many kind
of like practical
um questions in about like in which
situations would in a riemann model be
better
than a machine learning model and these
are kind of like very hard to to answer
in general
i recommend the textbook which i've
linked at the bottom and also
to kind of look at the different
benchmarking studies
okay maybe one short point about
facebook profit to my to my knowledge it
just implements a very specific
forecasting method
so it would be it would compare to a
framework toolbox to sk time like the
random forest brian's random forest
compares to sqlearn
yeah i think that's right
it's it's a fairly flexible model though
that they have um
well it's always a random for it yeah
yeah
okay um if there are no more urgent
questions at this point
um let's move on to the next notebook
and which is um time to use
classification
so this is a is kind of now in the panel
data setting
and i've tried to kind of like show
what's going on in this diagram here
um where we have um
training series which are labeled and we
have multiple instances of those
of those and then the goal is to to we
get a new series and we want to
label the new series so we basically
want to learn the association between
the series
and the labels
um so we import a number of functions
from sklearn and sk time
and then the specific data that we look
at in this um
notebook is um known as the arrowhead
problem
so we're basically trying to classify
the type of
arrowhead based on the outline
and this kind of like shows that um
timesheet classification
um can be used to solve a wide variety
of problems
so and basically how how you can go from
shapes to time
series is explained here so let's look
at so here they try to
kind of like um transform the and the
shape of a skull
into time series and if we look at kind
of like here panel c
um if we start at the mouth this gives
us our first time point so we
the the height here is the distance from
the center point
to the outline point and then we move
around it
and in like a clockwise fashion and we
always record the distance from the
center point to the up and to the
outline and then we kind of get this um
we transform the the outline of the
shape into the time series
and then we can try to see if the
different outlines
if they help us to predict the the type
of skull or in this case the type of
arrowhead
um and so in sk time we're going to have
this data set already so we can easily
load it
and we have in our training set we have
158
[Music]
instances and they're all univariate so
for all of them we have a single time
series
now this is where it gets um maybe for
some of you
somewhat unintuitive and if we look at
the data
this is basically what this like panel
data frame looks like
so each cell has an entire time series
in it
so if i take my x train
and i look into my first cell and it has
an entire time series in it
and the first number here is the index
the time index
and then we record the measurement value
so
for the zeroth index we observe this
value for the first time index we
observe this value and so on
so we um represent
entire time series as kind of like
columns
rather than just having um primitive
values like
floats integers or strings
as in kind of like the usual way of how
you would use pandas or or numpy
and again if you want to find out more
why we make this choice take a look at
the wiki entry here
where we discuss this in more detail
um if we look at the the our kind of
like target variable
we see that we have three classes
they're not perfectly equally balanced
um and we can plot them kind of like
here i just plot like the first instance
of each label
to kind of see what the the out the the
time series looks like of the different
arrowheads
and again we can ask the question um why
not just use some so i could learn
and again the answer is that yes you can
use scikit-learn
but um again you should be aware of um
certain kind of like implicit modeling
choices that you make when you use
scikit-learn to solve these issues
and they're basically two ways of how
you could do this
so the first way is um you treat each
time point
as a separate feature
so we can this is again what we call
tabularize here
so you can go from from this format up
here
where you have time series columns and
to this format here
where each time point now represents a
column
and this is a kind of like a standard 2d
matrix
um so you can use this and to fit your
cyclone regressor
now the the underlying modeling
assumption here is that
the the orderedness and time
of these observations doesn't play a
role
um so a tabular regression algorithm
cannot make use of the fact that the
columns are ordered
if you would reshuffle the the columns
um
you would still get the the same kind of
like
result the same fitted model and the
same predictions
um but we can use this um tabularized
training data
to for example fit like uh just to get
like a baseline for comparison
we can fit a dummy classifier or we
could fit a random forest classifier
sk time provides also like a transformer
for this operation
so you can make a pipeline where you
first tabularize the data and then you
fit the random force classifier
and you can run this as like a
encapsulated um meta estimator
so this is what i've explained in terms
of the the implicit modeling choice here
um and sometimes this works well and in
some cases it may be suitable
but sometimes it doesn't work well so
here the the kind of like what we want
to
to kind of like show is that um
that there is an implicit modeling
choice and that you should be aware of
this and that there may be other
strategies which are um more suited to
the program that you're trying to solve
um the other the other way so if we back
in this case
um where we have and features
the other way to go to the tabular
setting is to use feature extraction
so we could from each series that we
have we could extract certain features
and then this would also bring us back
to the tabular setting of psychic learn
and there's a a nice toolbox for this
called tears fresh
and it does like automatic feature
extraction for you
so here we kind of like show what this
looks like
we use our kind of like um panel data
data frame and we extract features from
it
and then we can see that for we have
like different variables so here for
example we
extracted the length here we extracted
the maximum value here we extracted the
mean the median
and so on and you can extract them a
number of our features
this is kind of the the minimal number
of features you can also
use different settings to get many more
features
and then once we have this um data frame
again you can
um you can fit a random forest
classifier
so in sk time you can formulate this as
a pipeline
um with the feature extractor first and
then the random forest
[Music]
okay i want to um show you one of the
other kind of like more specialized time
series classification algorithms which
we provide in sk time
which um um shows like a number of
interesting
um kind of things that you can do with
time series and this is called time
series forest and it's a
modification of the random forest
algorithm
um so the steps are you first
so for each instance you take the series
and you split it into multiple random
intervals
then the second step is for each
interval you extract the number of
features
and they can like original
implementation you extract the mean
the standard deviation and the slope
and then you basically if you extracted
10 random
intervals and you extract three features
from each of them
you end up with um 30 features for each
instance
and then based on that matrix you train
a decision tree
and then you ensemble um steps one two
three
so you ensemble this entire pipeline
including the data transformations and
the final decision tree
so in sk time we could write this as um
as this you can like somewhat shorter
form
and but this one here um explains it
better i think
so this these are the steps of the
pipeline
and in the first step you choose a
number of intervals so here we use the
square root of the length of the time
series
and then for each interval we we
transform we extract the mean
the standard deviation and the time
series slope
and then based on these features we fit
a um decision tree classifier from
circuit learn
and this gives us an individual um kind
of time series tree
and we can use that as well but we can
also ensemble this
so we fit multiple of these multiple
trees
and then average their predictions and
this is what we do in the time to use
forest
classifier
and another cool feature of this is that
we can still
get um feature importances from this
algorithm
and since we're working in the time
series domain
um we can get um
[Music]
kind of the feature importance graph so
we can understand the future importances
over time and this basically works by
aggregating
the importance of each feature from each
interval
and then kind of like normalizing it by
the number of intervals and estimators
and this may help us to like to better
understand um
which parts of the time series and which
which features of the time series
um are important to to discriminate
between the two classes or the three
classes in this case
um another variant of this is
called random interval spectral ensemble
in the economic time series
classification literature
and it works in the same way but here we
now extract them different features
so we extract the the autocorrelation
um here the autocorrelation coefficients
we also extract the
autoregressive coefficients
and the the coefficients of the power
spectrum
um but apart from that the the pipeline
is the same
and then we can ensemble it again using
this time series forest classifier
where we now pass the the rice the
random interval spectral ensemble tree
into um
[Music]
okay another interesting approach to
time series is
[Music]
is k-nearest neighbors and in
psychic learn what you do when you do
k-nearest neighbors classification
is you look at the distance between
individual data points
and you use something like the euclidean
distance and you always do like a
pairwise comparison
and when you want to compare entire time
series of course you could take the
euclidean distance between each time
point
and then average this but this
usually doesn't work particularly well
and the reason is that
time series may be slightly shifted as
you can see this image that the bottom
line is one time series
and the top line is one time series and
they're just slightly shifted
and the euclidean distance wouldn't be
um
very small for these time series but
when you allow
the kind of like matching between time
points when you give some kind like
slack to it and you allow this to be a
bit more flexible so that you can find
the nearest closest point
when you compute the distance um you can
you can kind of like define a similarity
measure
which is much more suited to comparing
time series
and this similarity measure is called um
is usually called dynamic time warping
or this idea of um
warping the series so that they align
and better with each other and i've
linked the wikipedia entry which is
i think fairly well written so you can
read more details on there
and we have this implemented in sk time
so here we load a different data set
which is a basic motions data set so we
record the
um the activities of
students wearing like a smart watch and
they do different activities um
they play batman and they run they stand
and they walk and the idea is
can we use this kind like profile
of movement to predict the class um
and if you look at the kind of like if
we plot all of the instances for
for badminton um they look very messy
and they don't look as if they follow
the same kind of lag pattern
and the same for running so if we
if we would just use the euclidean
distance it wouldn't work very well
but then if we allow them to to be
aligned
and through dynamic time warping it
works much better
and and we can show this here so this is
the standard cycle learn classifier
with the euclidean distance and this is
from sk time the
k nearest neighbor's time series
classifier using the
dynamic time warping
um this is
kind of like you could find out other
classifiers that we have and extra
resources here
now it's 9 30 and this is kind of the
end of the talk before we finish i want
to quickly
outline how you can get involved
and how you can get started so this is
in the how to contribute a notebook
so you can check out um the good first
issues that we have
and please feel free to hang out in the
um
discord after the after the talk and get
in touch
feel free to raise an issue or to chat
to us um
[Music]
um and it's all contributions are
welcome
so not just code um so we have a lot of
people who like
write them tutorials or you help us out
by
by designing the toolbox and the
interfaces
and yes so sk time is really a
community driven project
and where we would be very grateful if
you would get involved and give us some
feedback
all right thank you very much
thank you that was uh that was a really
nice talk
thanks good job i think you you managed
to to work it out well even though
virtual
yep yeah nice so uh yeah
normally this is the moment you you ask
for like an applause but that doesn't
really work
as well nowadays um but yeah thanks i
just been checking the discord in the
chat here and people seem to have really
enjoyed it
okay nice um yeah for follow-up indeed
what you said
the discord is available we're also
hosting sprints on saturday so actually
if you
if you got inspired by sk time and want
to contribute
maybe saturday is also a good time to to
meet some like-minded people there and
try to contribute a bit there's also an
interesting talk at
um lunch today by adrian um
[Music]
yes yes yeah it's just about saying
the schedule for today is still very
very interesting we have
a sprint preparation session on writing
unit tests
where giovanni lonzani will
actually show a unit test that he
written for pandas in preparing this
sprint prep session after that we'll
interview adrian
so adrian is a core developer for
psychic learn he's been involved with
another project called fair learn as of
recently
and we just want to pick his brain a bit
on sort of the things that he
is seeing there and tonight we have
three more uh
three more talks um on feature stores
on um how it is to contribute to open
source
and uh some lessons learned from
managing an open data platform and
using data for specific good so
hope to see you all then and i hope to
see you in discord
for now thanks